Then Truman announced the official surrender
this is a solemn but glorious hour i wish that
Franklin D Roosevelt had lived to see this day
General Eisenhower informs me that the forces of
Germany have surrendered to the United Nations
the flags of freedom fly all over Europe for
this victory we join in offering our thanks
to the providence which has guided and sustained
us through the dark days of adversity and
into light much remains to be done the
victory one in the West must now be won
in the East the whole world must be cleansed of
the evil from which half the world has been free
united the peace-loving nations have demonstrated
in the West that their arms are stronger by far
than the might of dictators or the tyranny of
military cliques that once called us soft and weak
the power of our peoples to defend themselves
against all enemies will be proved in the
Pacific war as it was proved in Europe